I thank you that's an excellent analysis
of how the establishment would view the
two different candidates and why they
would then decide that they could pull
behind bush and go with what you call
the a team again it still doesn't
completely explain why the B team that
is Dukakis and the Democrats didn't
fight harder for the president he didn't
go after bush more aggressively on this
Noriega drugs contra drugs the Iran arms
deals the whole relationships of Bush
and Reagan the ayatollahs why didn't
Dukakis and the Democrats use these
issues to probably win the election if
they could have publicized them it was
the negative campaign of Bush against
Dukakis that many people think helped
win it for Bush couldn't of Dukakis have
done an honest- campaign against Bush
telling the actual truth about bush and
why didn't I still have trouble of
course of course the Reagan
administration is the most corrupt in
the history of the country they've had
almost 200 people either indicted or in
jail for corruption and my
administration and the Democrats didn't
go after this it mentions you why well
this again gets back to the decision
they made I mean we can only site what
they did and then it speaks for itself
dan anyway running this committee a
Democrat you know made it a joint thing
and then the Democrats shut up and let
the Republicans use it as a forum to
advance the national security state the
CIA's activities the Contra program
instead of exposing the corruption
that's where the decision was made
Dukakis is just another member of the
team whatever economic miracle
supposedly occurred in Massachusetts
under his governorship was done in great
part with defense expenditures he is
bought into the system he's a member of
the team with the establishment as we
know as we've observed I remember
talking to les Kurtz about this when he
was developing the draft of his book the
the nuclear cage and we were talking
about the military-industrial the Iron
Triangle
the military industrial complex the
defense corporations the Pentagon and
the Congress and then we took it a step
further of course it includes the media
as everyone well knows the point of
alternative views is that the media is
owned literally by the same people who
own that you know the defense
corporations but then we took it a step
further it's not even a quadrangle it's
it's a pentad or pentagon because you
also have the universities the
educational system in which the defense
corporations and the Pentagon are
careful to invest heavily seventy
percent of some of these big
universities budgets come from from
defense you know money so the professors
are paid for the salaries are paid for
by the defense complex and so they
bought into the system so you have that
power structure and control and that
power structure determined not to let
the system be destroyed or be weakened
even at the price of their own let me
put it this way Jimmy Carter for example
he demonstrated this this what i would
call misdirected loyalty after the 1980
thing he did not go public and protests
the iran-contra deal he did not protest
it in october when he had these reports
coming in because he didn't want to
destroy the system of which he was part
to go back to another era 1960 richard
nixon lost to John Kennedy in a very
close election which turned in part on
on Mayor Daley in Chicago counting every
grave in Chicago twice now this scandal
was known at the time Nixon didn't
mention it until God knows twenty years
later he eventually said he couldn't he
couldn't make an issue out without
destroying the credibility of the
presidential election process and he
wanted to have another shot at the
presidency which again if which he got
and became president if he had destroyed
or attacked the system if he had exposed
that scandal it would have destroyed
perhaps it wouldn't take all that much
to lead the American people to have a
big mental break through and demand a
change in the system perhaps
the direction of a parliamentary system
where we could at the time of an
iran-contra scandal there would be
forced a vote of confidence and Reagan
certainly would have been out and in in
December of 8086 he would have been out
without this is my studies on the power
structure in the mass media this is the
main thing they try to keep from the
American public how the economic and
political system really works because
the Americans wouldn't like that at all
of they really they really knew saw how
scared the establishment dodged the
bullet how scared they got in the end
the Jackson run at the presidency this
last time because Jackson is the first
national prominent figure since I can
remember who has who has achieved
prominence and represents the interests
of the people pretty directly and the
the manipulations they had to go through
to keep him from getting a position of
of in fact power just to cite one
example of how far they will go wee-wee
this this loose Association of X's from
the national security we were flying to
Iowa to do a hearing to try to force the
candidates to tell us their policies is
by at that point there were a lot of
candidates and on the plane the day we
went up there the New York Times had a
big piece on where the polls put all the
candidates at that time in Iowa and it
had it had Simon I think was leading an
a big front-page article and and then a
long discussion Simon and Dukakis and
the others and wanted and then you went
to page three for the bigger article the
details and it turns out Jesse Jackson
was running a very close second it was
sort of like 30 32 31 but his name was
not mentioned on the front page of the
new york times or the time inside they
showed the polls but on the front page
they didn't want him to have the name
recognition well the times that all the
mainstream media pretty much did a
blackout on the excuse the metaphor on
the jackson campaign until the Super
Tuesday primaries where he won and then
he became a head actually after the
Michigan primers he was the front-runner
and then they had to give some attention
to Jackson and they tried to make it
negative and then Dukakis regain the
momentum in the Pennsylvania New York
primaries the party is probably the only
hope looking back the party machinery
shifted gears at that time scared
because Jackson was leading and there
was a chance that the people would
really get excited about this thing and
that fifty percent control asserted
itself the party machinery asserted
itself and Jackson was was pushed down
and Dukakis was run in instead they did
it by calling Jackson a radical they
said it's not racial we have no problem
with his skin color although there would
be some people in the South who wouldn't
vote for him but he's a radical meaning
he doesn't support the establishment and
they got that word out to the party to
you know to the party hacks throughout
the nation and the result is at Jacksons
and I've been wishing and hoping they
like what you said that Jackson would
split off and give us a third party and
with with the people that I believe
would follow him we might be able to
force onto the two-party system a viable
third party and then we could you know
throw our block of votes to the right or
the left depending on who would give us
the most real concessions I don't think
Jackson will ever get these concessions
from the Democratic Party which is where
he's trying to notice the election night
I flipped on one channel I think it was
NBC and the analyst was saying well the
reason the caucus lost was because
Jackson spoke out for him and then I
immediately turned to the next channel
which was ABC and that pendant was
saying well the reason he lost was
because Jackson refused to support it
which is total nuts yes Jackson was
traveling all over the country literally
every day campaigning you know ten
things a day he was doing her you know
many on his this was followed up I saw
it a big Newsweek article analyzing the
election and it said well they were
looking at the prospects for the future
and they said the only thing the
Democrats can do is to go with people
like Gary Rob who are conservatives so
the Democrats can move to the right they
said the worst thing they could do
be go Jesse Jackson because it would
tear apart the Democratic Party and
destroy it every election with the
centrist liberals like Mondale and
Dukakis but you're talking about the
Democrats in there another problem which
Democrats had and that is they went
lockstep right along with Reagan and
reaganomics and providing money for the
code truce our whole arms bill
absolutely see the arms build-up for
example the money that the power
structure that keeps the democrats in
office the ones that are in office the
this is reaganomics paid off enormously
for them now that you do get into a lot
of individual struggles and and
infighting and and you know the system
it isn't a monolithic it isn't uh the
controller's of the country being in
lockstep not at all some of them
actually jump out of the windows of
their office buildings in New York
committing suicide on occasion it's
there's a lot of tugging and pulling but
nevertheless when the chips are down the
establishment will will not go for the
jugular vein their own juggler vein if
you will they will cooperate in a
cover-up Howard Baker you know going in
to straighten out the Reagan White House
there by perhaps forever abandoning his
shot at the presidency Nixon you know
refusing to expose the scandal Jimmy
Carter refusing to expose the San
dukakis you decide to talk is refusing
to expose the scandal Lyndon Johnson's
behavior after they'd killed John
Kennedy the Warren Commission cover-up
you know let's get back to business as
usual let's calm the nation down let's
not take the scab off the wound you know
and let the people see let's let's paper
it over and cover it up put a bandage on
it and get on with business as usual
because of what's at stake is the
viability of the system for them for
them so to draw a conclusion to wrap up
our discussion today it would seem that
we really can't expect from the
Democrats or the media any real
exposures of the scandals and corruption
of the system any real important efforts
to change or reform or transform the
system they're really depends on the
people
that we're the only active agents of
change that it depends on alternative
media alternative socially critical
progressive researchers to dig this dirt
up that this is sort of our obligation
that if change is going to happen it's
not going to come from the Democratic
Party it's not going to come from the
media can only come from the people so
that our obligation during the bush
years is to be critical vigilant and
militant in trying to smoke out all of
these scandals and get rid of bush and
force the system to change that that's
the only way change comes about it